in the members thank you for the nice
Benton what's up Wounded Knee emergency
evacuation master please note that this
meeting will be audio recorded and
should we be required to evacuate the
building which you please leave the room
Bonjour societies that escapes their
gaze please hold both hands of Isis
there in a wet cloth different if anyone
is unable to instead they please allow
others texts before they go to the size
of a cool so they can then be given
assistance our identity points will be
in common probably car park at the size
of acidic foods please do not delay
evacuations closing blowing clean do not
return the building and took a position
to mobile council staff I've number one
apologies wratten's we have several
colleges from counselor Dre kandla
Hazelwood comes ashore counselors of way
and council melon and it's salable pass
on our best wishes count them in think
that's appropriate LMK and counselor web
is substituting the Civil War counselors
short so it can't the weather to discuss
insurance ashore and I've some to
non-members attendings got camping in
Port Stephens welcome and I tanam treat
over I've not remit of the meeting held
in the ninth or November and everyone
has had been circulated to them remember
capital funds please yep thank you very
much like to do that
any declarations of interest none and
they could move on to item 5 any updates
on so foggy software remember going to
be seen briefing notes resentfully by
polling and with a very brief report
which has been issued oceans bug be
shown in am not attending my meetings
and we have no other Denali dedicated
officers attended margin for common
particular subject and the book is there
is a big book force are very
specifically regarding the amount of
induction as a target tend to send
remember to say that it's horrible and
rs means that the reduction beam little
anything we are the recommendation is
that the committee resulted to know the
contents of this report i am aware that
there are some question that members
would license put to all four four two
offices of the council particular i
think short run those questions are
between writing if we have those
questions for that great we're all happy
with questions of our which of them will
be delegated the authority to manage
this and are they suits been qualified
to do so very demand how much we rely on
the PLT system there's a question
regarding hope devices when the
cancellation of initiative the world
when I've had fun possibly i think i
think it from the point of view that a
terminal
one of our pictures of saliva software
is good and therefore that would be a
saving if it wasn't required in the
cloud so that's the Nexus on which I
raised it and therefore it does raise
the question of the continuation or not
by the Council of the youth that I thank
the members and certain offices and to
ask to ask the question is is a policy
of some own United likely to be reviewed
at a policy foots council shortly so we
don't know that in addition to say that
we believe that the assistant director
for IT and human resources it raises the
expectation that there would be a
considerable savings from the redundancy
or virus and very hard associated
software that it would appear that any
decision soon she needs to own devices
both the men's and for the staff and
this may not be this may not be possible
and therefore we'd like to understand
the impact of that okay thank you very
much I believe function under family
camp the new balls has a question
regarding the end bar and supposedly all
that work on time anthem is that we
cover that we've been out to several
questions issues yet all again fabulous
because every 100 usually great the
pre-sentence it with yes or no glad you
love it actually that they little at the
female company you have reload detail
every question you know because ya kasa
panic I've got to know what the
correlation of the cost of the iPads is
in relation to paper and documents
ok for question 3 cantilever thank you I
don't what to ask a question but I would
like to put on record and the hard work
that was done by our former employee and
regret the fact that we rely heavily on
his knowledge of the council system on
his expertise and I think that should be
noted because the fact that he is no
longer here doesn't make the work that
he input in the savings that he
generated any less important thank you
very much something that problem
dissolving as well importantly third
question passion on the publication's of
the office again foot which people me
encanta any other members any questions
or comments regarding pull and live on
the little one chance to read in and
nobody supposes that remain in the clear
only one area so every site if it
possible to get breakdown of this budget
that's all I know HS is just a summary
isn't it back up the motivation that I'd
certainly like to have a little bunnies
that eventually three-point oh yeah
eclipse or not very point for the
summary of piglets I actually like a
little where the budget in trendy reason
why we can't have that information I
think that in light not having an expert
at the council anymore
I'd like to look at that information
generally give a suggestion and the
suggestion is can we form a small pass
group seem to do that because we did do
that previously and it was very helpful
to work together as a team and I think
you know we could probably do that so if
we were Jim to request that a nap days
of that spreadsheet which was provides
us with all the third party software on
it together were to take our waters with
the spend of over 2,000 pounds a year it
might if that might full were canceling
you bullies in awesome g-dub or the
other one because it falls out all four
powerful that is fearful that just made
it either four number I think that one's
in our country so at the moment we've
got former students of all three
children and request for a photocopy of
the third-party contracts over and above
4,000 pound propane approach come on
take off from it education in are you
intending for all this to go to a
transcript all the questions no now the
previous questions willfully managing
director should be a thermochemical on a
short which orbit unit you will notice
on the turnpike something okay and
people see all you have are did we get
breakdown of the budget is that just for
the 2017-18 budget old please that
precum importing down and 315 60 or I
often displayed fix things if they are
all or fixing something you know 1550
mmm they see
if all three budget figures are listed
there yeah interterra the proposal for
confirmation that we have a small
working pocket meant to sound one and
we're in mind the sums of money in the P
and apparent difficulty of the council
has women it's a fallacy that a moment
perhaps we should say that soon around
the item I defer to cancer mostly by the
suggestion I never understand women
don't make the main jury it feels like
it's like pressure being put on and I
don't want to put pressure on the
council but I think it might be
difficult for this to be done given my
accountant talent in migrating systems
we happily thoughtful i can certainly
think of the managing director saying
look was an awkward off going on in the
migration this may not be the right time
to do this could we could we ask for
advice on where they think this will be
possible rather than sooner rather than
later yeah look like what they don't yet
and the chance just ask me we'd be
better sound the task group after you've
seen the imagine director has miksa me
for the response that we've got the
answers in the budget was down from evil
for their binax will there be x1 Sam let
me pass don't be fun with hella get a
response to what we can get a response
to buy your end result is
you may get a full what should I tell
very good songs you want and i'll get
one you get one good eye bridgend ever I
think the concern there mr. Chen is
whether me obviously would turn up again
but so easily well I mean all time to
get those while I think it says that
we're one of the questions were asking
which offices is going to be that goes
with this exactly it is not Shawn's
button and it is another person liable
to be requested within committing any
patient presents one certification
feminism physical order to put it here
and they are so are we happy to perform
any questions and requests for
third-party contracts and budget pipe
down arcing this we can have that prior
to the next week in February because
they shouldn't watch baseball with
vandalism side Chairman I know over one
side wants one last question of Zombo so
if you just had your chances so it will
be like quickly just clarify and another
question could you just clarifies
telecoms is included in the ICT contract
case on the don't have any wakakakakaka
series here is relatively there anyone
knows that's nice okay well I I have a
distinct feeling in control hardly there
is not in a different company but then
that is very simple question is other
testicle
that is really happy with that I would
like to know that then I would like to
know what that is whose responsibility
that that's fall on that we have changed
problematic is going to be linked
together yeah you know we are selling
but underneath there might be more
questions will be sorry I was reported
it is a question you know I understand
why you running the question oil is
there are huge budget implications and
telecoms as well yeah thank you I think
so yet we will prefer not offer and then
we mentioned that we would also
recommend that is being revisited next
year I'm endlessly ones that we called
in to the finish from now on we are
those my County Route 7 i'd rather size
of a separate matter
consideration of the work plan for 2017
18 I think it would be appropriate for
some time during their year so we're
going to visit the new contract so I'm
in than having content of difficult for
penalties for the question gives a
satellite and quest for further
information sinful soon Sean's sperm and
that Billy agrees with you will look at
situation again in the Imperial 1783 is
for you what has been closed back from
some time to moving on trimming the
custom lumbar city should review
Constitution and a long and simply big
meeting respond thank you i like them by
coming along and we will have email to
us quite a comprehensive list of changes
are being made of this range of
constitutions hat for the sake of
members are aren't on the world and
parties to give a very brief overview of
the work the Emancipation so far with
those members I just give them a bit and
I think that's where we are now and
estimates the completion interesting
cover Jamie essentially and the views of
concentration is quite a hefty piece of
work and we might try it as a lesson but
you try to break it down to you
and the first phase was to look at the
summary Parkland Hospital whistle blows
policy and officers code of conduct in
addition to that is working group itself
and commanders have identified issues
cackles and other members have seen
buzzing of tissue paper and then we'll
coat for my experience and what I've
encountered and their arty also
right-click may mean look at this report
essentially in the result of the first
work first we're moving back in a moment
so important but it so much and N and
yes is it happy thought that a lot of
the changes are much needed updates
really an example that still reference
to and if the ELA reference mate has
expanded border me and that was
abolished back in two thousand twelve so
that's essentially update this is a
report of phase one and not fall off a
dream has been completed the first on
issues that notion that means an
investigation lasting whether I'm going
quickly and the working with itself the
next meeting has been set up to the 25th
annual thank you for lunch calculus
Thank You mr. chairman I'm after welcome
report and I think that remembers our
own for luck working part they probably
don't realize how much work is going to
the bottom the officers who are being
sexually diligent and hardworking
because it's a complex if a very worthy
document and it's complicated and there
has been a very positive approach I
think everyone would agree on the
working party it doesn't look in some
ways that a lot of work has been done
our part 1 and part 2 but are
effectively the skellington
components on which the rest of the
Constitution hangers forgive me a rock
that's how I read it and that is ninety
percent complete and at this various
issues that are outstanding which are
going to be dealt with on the 23 but the
book the work on those who has been done
and that is a tremendous amount of work
going forward side difficult complement
these two obviously work involved and I
would like to move the amended
recommendation that has been passed
around because I think that that is
exactly what we decided at that time
that are working partly the only thing I
would like to note is that image 3.9
reported said that it is recommended for
areas of prostitution not in need of
medication will not be reviewed I don't
unfortunately I think the whole
Constitution will needs we look at that
as if that's only for noting lots of
agreement I'm not going to be picky on
that I was with the chairman with your
provo if there's no questions other
questions remember that to move the
recommendations one and so is called
circulated all remember the linear
equations this is the Dozen brother John
Smith it was a very substantive changes
that remind it was worrying a new year
the changes are for the first onion and
the councilman said was and these
changes made and it may look like simple
amendment and updates actually there's
no actually when we mean substantive
action technical miracle yeah I love it
it's actually just updating on it the
outstanding elements such such as the
looking at public speaking looking at
substitutions
the others are more substantive nearly
are earth Queen still looked at because
changing and the Constitution be taken
lightly changes that are made here
updates it keeps in mind current
education keep it in mind you're making
I think the aim of the work group as
make it small plane is mr. the rateable
value things to change of the word
system presents more user-friendly lots
of that obligate the sleds has been
changed I believe it's a modern updated
change Joan I would only like to comment
and have service report has not just
come see member review converse
customary have gone to all members of
the council so I really did that happen
what I'm also bleed it will go to a full
council in quite a few weeks time so I'd
like it community that all members of
the council should take the opportunity
of reading with you know tons three
peaks over a period of time so that they
when they arrive at full council Senate
asking arabic sense here give judgment
so think there's a piece of work but for
everyone on the council to answer this
whole protest chairman if I may can I
also make comment on the timescales I
know everyone is using imagine
I a short time scales but I hope
councilman connection that support
nerves but as a piece of what goes on
it's bigger memory you know ideally i'd
love to get it done within six months of
like them and haven't spoken to other
motion offices in ethics i have been
warned that been prepared going along
the fence project I don't want to very
expectations' that this is a sick and
cyclic ginger you presented at the
working party with quite detailed time
frame and I think it wasn't because one
day out there but we would have liked
that there would be an incident
flexibility in language in the work more
than happy to to recognize just
presented the month but yeah so he's the
god I mean you are I need to our tools
and I hope that I think most members
would recognize councilman pathetic they
see me butters a substantial child under
all what changes you have so many
smaller boards it'll be tough nothing
remember happy to accept it was
conservative you started on my tummy
expected I think what none of the
founders anticipated was how difficult
small change of wording could do we need
a magic needed updating but by updating
you've got to be careful and I think
this muscle power which concerns the
breath we are not trying to alter the
Constitution what we're trying to do is
make sure that it recognizes present-day
practice and where there is an intention
in the Constitution that hasn't been
perhaps put into practice or fertilized
we're trying to clarify those points and
that the time factor on this is going to
be a lot longer than we anticipated
however and I think Angela will probably
agree with us our suspect please at the
next meeting we should be able to
complete part 1 and part 2 it doesn't
sound as love but if we go that would be
a substantial that will be after getting
turned down and my suspicion is that
part 3 will be a lot harder I really
would you agree with that I agree when
you're leaving there a while ago yo any
left yeah we just want to emphasize the
scalloping importantly 21 members and
obvious quality people working I think
we do appreciate that and we think I
don't think we have to assert that the
initial time scale of April is not going
to be achievable for compliments there
is much I was only going to say no
personally I recognize that it's along
the task in April and recognizing the
paltry is quite considerable in this
piece of work I think by jumping exam
alrighty you even when pass rates
flowering character classes and Angeles
things to consider even by our jumps on
part three because I'm absolutely sure
that though the lots of consideration
for lenders
so the bottom of all the bite-sized the
better it also gives a very real
impression of things are moving I don't
think people might projects game longer
provided there's a series of milestones
that make sense and in carefully with is
perceived my intention to feel and we
have been but it is one gentleman I
accept it for what that i will keep
members updated and inverse image it
will get spanked life but when you hit
is because when you start look at a talk
it's probably don't realize that and
then you might have to break it down but
you all know that Julie Colin Pascoe any
other questions member okay so members
have gotten an amended recommendation
it's been put before the planet hi Devon
had chances to read that with vendor
agreements and run under conditions
improve them okay thank you very much
anymore what we save them come on this
yes I thank you it is law as I'm putting
our people are on record with Peter
because he wasn't intending to be on
these and to put that on a pond on hold
follow Thursday I spied every day in
circles but you know thank you for doing
on your facebook employee be printing
hi people total King City got a partner
for the lymphatic system which favorite
a million okay and the first ones i
think politic the cabin sewing and
comparison Sebastian the narcotics you
saw this document it was rich even open
bar from Berlin factions sighs to call
the night
and now that give me some of the
questions arising is writing for the
consultation but they hope that they'll
be in a position to make a decision by
the engineering and the street scene
enforcement policy that's the move down
to the 31st bookmark and look being
there and the reason is warming on that
one funky set the ground there is no
change on man that's still the other
febrile decision on them the only new
one in the air hockey action plan cancel
Stanley person from absolutely horrible
avoid tears I got a customer for you
watch your question oh I see so you can
plant do that all the time under the
street scene I'd like to know why we are
not I I cannot believe the guys this
parking enforcement is accessibility a
car today we service gets and nothing do
you but this is more littering shoprite
tipping and think that is the
environment with packs enormous
nothing to me pumpkin hardship lot and
naturalyte of it cancel that valchek
question has to the apples that are
given me down but if the other is not is
what we are what you wanted a son and so
I could help scandalous and it's very
bitter be like 50 likes of you I is
policy I do know that some Marcus hatem
you make we'd set on the twenty-eighth
the November to discuss the fallout and
I thought it's all out in a bit like an
usual war the full council when matters
the set don't seem to be attending to
including their disposition is enough
staff that's been against by Marcus
except on the twenty-eighth novella is
not on this King decision but it is a
matter of time and kasumi person so are
quite happy to include accessories you
want hoops for whether it was hopeless
at kathleen's me is a very real risk or
can I enjoyed it after that it's been
gone work planned for next year's the
lizards we went around the counselors
huh so they don't have the least amount
of excitement a little bit as a real
bracelet and my question will be to
decide because it doesn't relate action
to the word on a piece of paper under 15
16 that some very minor children that
you know this is about putting the air
quality action plan in place and that
has been a consultation I wonder if our
offices of having feedback at all on the
number of responses who are received a
response
patient during its progress over the
last six weeks or so i can tell you that
there are 41 responses and including the
statutory consultation deborah as it can
counsel counsel point Borough Council
and Lady town council certain residents
businesses including public transport
writer and is driven 10pm those are the
individuals I can't give you a breakdown
wait wait wait they already they don't
know d well only there's obviously can't
cheer America back on right I don't want
to dwell upon back at all or perceive
that question further except that this
should get another consultation where
I'm hearing very low numbers Gary core
response rates and which is about our
work plans for next year I know that our
community involved policy for planning
has been significantly revised by plan
policy committee in the truth local
council within the last six months so I
know that that is well up to to date and
he's actually very responsive I do
recall that when the system directs
planning the was when you came along
with that she also mentioned that there
are other policies that talk about other
consultations and other communications
policy so those would appear to be I
think out of date given what we're
seeing as a response in these
consultations and I'd like that you
commit you to consider putting the work
plan for a 2007
anything I review those other policies
that relate to communications and
consultations of the council with the
public yes thank you Jeff christian
academy oh yes please so I just skip
them back to and my pants were standing
laughing about street scene enforcement
badly what up showed up what what is the
internal review of the service areas
undertaken what does that mean to you
the bottles of flesh argan she
understand that i mean i cooked rom
flesh it out but i thought he would be
speculating when i get the feeling he's
looking at the very stuff is 102 which
ones would be available to do
enforcement yes that's possible I mean
that's always been the issue the end
there the officers searching a random
doing the important okay so but I I'm
purely speculating on that I would have
to go into markers and asking so so so
if i just come back on that so give them
given that would there be any budgetary
implications of action being taken yeah
i was making if even see you tonight or
is only needed more staff there would be
a budgetary implications that's why
probably looking to try and use existing
staff but really i'm speculating maybe
the budget way they feel better give you
more information on these four we could
also move against it off this is the
class support of it anyone
oh my gosh what activity in Marcus to
circulate you know yes yes I'm that
rather than country committee I'm in
circulation I to all members there he
don t like I haven't we mentioned about
only the 15 16 which is near college
action back who I think it will all make
sure what time and it's whether or not
we ask for an upload posting this came
for the nudity in October I'm not quite
sure how much of an update there would
be if I'm honest but I don't see that as
an excuse not to our and that gave that
the operation handsome mr. makes a nice
feedback from the consultation is full
power that update if anyone was like
that I meet Jim shelling when you're
just speaking to the point you right now
I think it's fine for us to express
views on what we'd like to see in the
work plan for 17 18 and I think anything
that's cause you know concern and you're
right there's going to be a plan and
what we don't know is really what times
go that's going to be acted upon and
what other things need to be done or we
should follow through so I'm calling in
favors saying you know I think it's
something should go on the plan what I
don't know what in things yourself
exactly what some particular channel I'd
be looking down in me but that's not the
problem the problem for this committee
is to ensure the beginning of the year
we've got a very good view I've got our
arms round everything we what we wanted
to do and be able to create
you are planning itself you know I know
things will come along during the year
that we have to deal with ad hoc but you
know I think it's great area of gross
for you remain September for CSC be
expressed their disappointment to the
upper done when he arrived without a
satisfactory report and obviously often
quiz they come back in October I think
he understood the committee's feelings
regarding the design around the air
quality management plan you are not
being given to the improvement of this
visitor parking another that's not the
composition and include details about
consultation and the thing back on
unconstitutional three months ago if
numbers are happy middle it's just an
update such a request for nothing I
think at this stage is that although we
can ask because I only maybe an awful
lot of new information available to
Germany five minutes online in the
injection ask while we adding this to
this current work plan and agree in what
month actually oh yeah we are on now so
that's that's why I say hennecke to your
plan and you got Shawn as well there
haven't you got all right I think it's I
think it takes to advance chairman if I
play by mine to give you no time for
these things through the consultations
they can play yes it won't be too
probably too much work to assume
the sausage but of course it is quite
that question yeah a beefy plan it's
going to involve ringway Jacobson X
County Council and quietly work I'm not
trying quickly namely well actually that
probably so they don't move very quickly
I like nothing happened several melanoma
that it was weak ideas that stimulated
by white balance in which i would i
would suggest period it's almost a
certain people the work plan for next
year and it's the only one yeah okay
countries different i did its what the
air quality actually playing rightly
town center now with the increased
traffic has been liable or pop my
Waukesha's robford and obviously the
airport and there as well is this going
to the action plan gonna be spread out
more or is it just going to be
concentrating on the live each answer
from our china and then the best I can
but I'm not the expert suitable to wear
such a big change so we have it so you
are going out the only thing ever right
Leela former basically writing and
collagen cleared area because they filed
on the pantry and because they further
on the monitoring hasn't been reported
that front and then we have to come up
with a plan to reduce that pollution and
bring it within acceptable legs there is
what the plan is producing that current
time is supposed to them okay at the
moment and the previous meeting boxford
is not showing levels sufficient to be
reported to deference
have all the levels because you know
what would be the new palace and Skye
jewelry and that we've got new kwachas
of housing going on the airport is now
up and running when was rocks requested
and is it going to be tested again as I
understand it there are certain spots
across the district the intended on six
month basis right thank you and there is
some in rockford and across the rest of
the district at this bar as per their I
can't actually I'm not the xperia and I
couldn't tell you where they are I just
remember Emily if I could help it
England hope that with circulated I had
the levels in there I thought me what
they were lives all the information was
in there but while I was wanting to know
that when was their levels taken and are
they paying some readily because the
traffic through Oxford is increasing and
you know it increased many times since
I've lived there 20 years ago it is
being taken on a regular basis or it is
I can fix most roads flow hablar and
where was the last one payment status by
German German there anything there is a
through the website where all the
results from and Roger districts mari
air quality monitoring have been
published along with those develop small
ever
excited there's quite a few groups over
ethics or living in this question all I
can forget to counselor people is answer
book his particular question going to
that going to that website what will
answer them all I would also say to him
if he reads the minutes of the review
committee in October I can't see the
cool where you were over here or not I'm
not making a point and that I'm just not
sure you'll find the exam there are
comments made about their non going
monitoring programs so i recommend you
having a look at that because i don't
want to you picked it into any other
area Jeremy Jeremiah does that happen
could be quite welcome to contact martin
houses and you can answer it avail any
technical questions you may have thought
anything you can be found with the
unicorn and then I while our technical
elements to that reporting the godson is
just the technology as well it takes a
while to get head around terminology
cattle boat painting tips found the
record online programs and email trail
and ethics and all WK is the website all
we just gotta break down across a
district council by monitoring the full
president's own circles everything
there's and online Thank You counselor
anybody any other questions regarding
key decision document or any specific
awesome
[Music]
okay hi Jen do outside work time again
we will be presiding remember I hope
they don't have holiday if you haven't
we don't yeah really need coffee it was
last to come on by Daryl comprises
technical presentations maybe we might
you know yes I like talking to you ok
George made attention to the origin bone
next month agenda tributary management
strategy silence yeah investment
strategy and
polity five minutes then there's a reply
from holiday and we have factory napping
this came as well and in into that we
long and short and ed it's against the
factory for Hamilton who is so again we
hurried I'm in the property holder yes
you can enjoy the defense counsel of
love in Sochi as will we not see the
Constitution working perfectly hopefully
we'll have some really happy that it's a
little bit complicated or crowded are we
going to give century housing a time
span as we did with the hospital so that
without have things going on and on and
on I think it has be one I think you
highlighted as give another legal aid of
it jam-packed running is potential club
night Kathy I here looking at the work
and I think we've got to be you know
working smart smarter the word I was
always being asked to say under the
houses are paid I feel sure that members
who received the last report and where
we got to I'm sure it would be possible
to members of this committee to put to
fall what questions I would like to ask
i know i have but i'm just reminding
people it could that will then make that
Hannibal in the sense of time and if we
have questions of sanctuary that are
beyond the major question we ask the
question we ask sister ship during that
remind ourselves was sanctuary have a
program of housing development and we
didn't know I also didn't know what that
program was we haven't heard any more
since the management director or chief
executive of sanctuary games and update
prior to the lots of Housing Board
disappearing and I think that's the
question we need to send to the dress
and I think it would be very good idea
to put a time aside for that and I think
it's something we want to receive rather
than I don't think they'll take your
colleagues are too many questions like
can't be doing quicker I do more I just
get a feeling that going to cause a bit
of a bit of a fracture with the
council's is did some years ago that was
a major fracture so is it something like
20 minutes for a presentation is it
about something like 20 minutes for 400
estimating 40 overall giving time for
all the other things on the agenda I'm
just making a suggestion from how we
work work smart but I mean off the back
of Captain nation comment there Paul
will search our members and notes and
minutes from previous meetings regarding
heinzmann and sanctuary housing which he
was 20 I making food and if you ever
loses sanctuary welcome if we really
anything that question some housing
development we know that a wildlife I
think about a year when there was a
significant fracture between century and
the rocks of Housing Association and the
council the question was regarded Lee
in front of the press as well somehow
found their way quite quite patents
coming and that the observation was
there was only 50 houses to be built and
they hadn't actually done and that
caused the major fracture of
relationships between sanctuary and I
think it would be a shame that that
happened again so I think we have to be
thoughtful how we approach it and how we
conduct ourselves and just know that
such a microwave members have got
questions in them on the radio it comes
to me they could put them to pull first
important subjugated and you can make
them some idea of timing and how many
question can be asked or person yes we
took after the home defence you put it
around the areas you want to cover and
you let me know I'll make sure they're
there in the report which will make it a
tin you know rather than I have cancer
lonely and how they've invited about
separately i am going to be here in and
thankful seven reasons we've got another
specter hanging and i'm sure everyone
does ism you it will know that there's
any position that's being run by
residents and questioning the council's
with them or otherwise with regard
francisco t loads and Clarence Council
Clarence logic I remember exactly and
it's now reached the position on that on
the e-petition on Troy gang use my
knowledge that it succeeded 750 which
means that the very least to be doesn't
get for 1500 petitioners that as i read
that issue comes before the reviews
maybe and in terms of our work plan i
see it's very so if it is surpassed that
it's a matter for review committee to be
filled as a result of the petition i
think when you separate making
colin is an emotional i think the
petitioners expires with 17 sorry so
true peaceful march went to anyone true
but i think casual is Mason's made a
very important because when you interest
and everything out and the organization
of their meeting I think we would have
to move the chamber and have it for one
item painting as we have to be an extra
inning so now Hannah my local culture
typically not notice or traffic you I
have a proper 1200 of the mandible is it
yeah it was been a larger capsule nickel
Oh commander and clarify please about
third-party software but that means is
that going to move to the seventh of
fatness that much yes blend Sean will
again ok ok this one magic horrible club
it will be a very long meeting let me
pick in timing so we can give the time
that we want him to appear so that he
doesn't have to pick from everything ok
simply having someone probably one may
be in attendance to be careful pungent
hoping that the treasury management is
Olivia then last is spend on the office
of so depending on I will be thing to
have ignited and battle for Education
Council mrs. mayor mentioned the
competition we expect in scopus februari
did you say the local cultural and 25th
a failure alexander tidy up hopefully to
write a report and I got Down syndrome
red lines I'll no good timing problem
I can't get into controlling too often
is so has March or the answer yeah well
that's fun how much should we do it'll
be anything four lines of doing a
physical reaction as a friend any other
questions with all the worldwide
canceling practice a little bit more
research on the air quality monitoring
frantic hour it would appear that is
none he watched put itself into the sky
concern the deer quality monitoring
segmentation walls industrial estate in
rail equine street it's also very
quality my dreams eggs bacon champagne
but there is no not return conference I
consultants capsule evil and then cancel
German just so my character web for all
of industrial site has been removed that
we monetary particle matter and the Air
Quality Management Area for that was a
revoked so far data the difference
between size no sir Ganga everything I
hope that's powered by that fundamental
understanding those L thinking well
hello according to this website which
are shown up today it's raining high
street and if it were so they are very
organized should do something honestly
so the apples and view of the
particulars already been pointed out the
morning Ross has been taking away
Oakland and the one in I do believe the
one in value our streak was taken away
as well out because it was working on
listening conservation area that the new
ladies so those are taking away our
offices senior officers so long told
from
a mulching owlish so as I say I deal
with these new plans to read and to be
address the situation championship thank
you develop it was a slight confusion he
about the Air Quality Management Area
and a quality monitoring and in quality
monitoring is something that can be done
anywhere if it's a careful 35 wherever
anyone is concerned about the Imperial
Air Quality Management Area is what
comes into play while there is a known
problem and the only known problem we
have is in Riley and that is the only a
qma and that for the areas of this
committee has been looking at because
that come under and the gingiva air
quality monitoring in general we haven't
looked up as a committee or in other
council we would hope that our offices
were in fact they could say that in
casual monitoring return that's another
issue cancelling so if we haven't done
the monitoring in rochford we won't now
have any problems I think instead I
think you really need if you've got
concerns to scream to my helmet and
you'll get a give you chapter of birth
of we're monitoring being done chances
are good I understand that measurements
have been taken in rocks could in the
past but the quiz late were so low I
have been discontinued thanksgiving i
would agree with that
suggestion but i will go say to anyone
who is concerned about the distribution
of some past and current monitoring
stations but there is an open invitation
in the men in souls be october review
committee for members began can see talk
to email marketing our and suggest areas
where further monitoring should be
undertaken thank you can't the nipple
well just like that suggests that it
remembers the other concern about air
quality that say we need to look at
eject is the why they want those areas
monitor mixes earth this is and what
marked in hallett said to me is that he
wouldn't be happy through various hasn't
you know if the air quality though okay
so if we just what casually went along
as it did you monitor that area he would
say he doesn't think so Alicia's his
opinion if he look you know he's not
prepared so monitor areas and to prove
that there is all isn't a problem he
based it on his opinion and i don't
think that's the strategy that the
council should take so you start to use
it easily sleeps the martin Alex and you
know decide how far you want to progress
with them should should we have a
quality monitoring across the district
as it's so personal in the news-press &
already knows asking for it can sustain
it is not just to pick up on what the
report said we have been talking to just
have it all the whys and wherefores as
to
how or what degrees the result of air
quality as it as we pointed out is he
any opinions in his opinion and i don't
know i hope that qualified enough for an
opinion that it's not necessary to do
those we don't know what quality of
areas around station around Watford or
oh where is in town there is no
mechanism most directly as I said most
of Records be taken why because of
senior officials which haven't been
night which on quite disgusted E that it
should be got that they should be
conditionally doing it to be shown to be
doing and after the nose of the quality
of air in London as may lead to
outsiders we should be doing even more
tests and these are not very expensive
tests to don't at all I mean you might
die cuz the bear the bear and that
sounds of those can easily go across the
district for air quality forms of West
sold at the site sometime ago and I
can't remember where they were but there
should have been a record of where the
measurements are taken thank you I'm
it's worth one doubt reminded members
that this is has another word plan for
next year and some other things that we
just dressing now there can be you can
make sure most physically there are
certain secure areas that we want to do
have a cigar sir air quality monitoring
kept some spice to say which is an
actually management area the ACMA it's
just regard to monitor images a separate
issue then that can be discussed next
image in cabin
I just think if we if we straight into
this I think is sometimes useful just to
exchange in things that do occur to us
as we go look these settings will will
also come up is a guard's planning
application that they'll always be a
part of the planning report that
considered their quality and like we
take advice from other statutory
consultative our experts and in
particular is County Council for
highways as its County Council a lot of
other things during the education in our
case we have an environmental health
department with a principal officer who
will give that advice to the planning
department and it will form part of a
key liberation the weight that's given
for that that advice is something that
they will tell you they will tell us and
for us to consider so they are the
experts they are the ones who inciting
so when we emphasize in his opinion he
is an expert and we have to have regard
to that thank you thank you very much
any more questions and then okay thank
you well and so see you at eight thank
you very much
[Music]
[Music]
also if I will not fight because we get
several days early
I am so sorry I'm guilty of it so you
wanna make one drop on please then we do
this extinguish equipment and a little
increase in resided which is why is
inside 10 kilometers and acquaintances
energy-efficient where the whole match
are you finding our conferences
[Music]
[Music]
another thing about